dieter officials say a new staff the
department are increasing the amount of
claims being processed
thank you for joining us for this
special edition of eight news now at
seven o'clock or 6
50 to be specific i'm brian loftis and
i'm denise valdez
200 new staff started last week and they
are just plowing through a backlog of
claims
joe muller tells us how consolidating
all those claims into one place
may really help speed things up in an
interview monday deter officials talked
progress 200 welfare workers are now
trained and started working on claims
stuck between portals
they just finished their first week of
actually working on those claims and
they got through just about 5 000
of them saturday the allorica call
center stopped processing pool claims
starting this week all of those calls
will be dealt with back at dieter
something they think will help the
difference there is the folks who are
answering the phones can also
handle both pua and ui questions
and progress for claimants and we think
that that's really going to help
a mass disqualification notice will be
sent out within the next few weeks for
claims that are having issues with
identity verification
this will disqualify fraudulent claims
if claims are not fraudulent
this will give people the opportunity to
verify their identity there'll be about
9 000 of those going out shortly that's
people that did not follow through with
id me
and we believe almost all of those are
fraudulent claims
so it's significant progress they say
disqualifying fraudulent claims will
speed up the process for real ones
as far as appeals go the notification
system is being worked on and
notifications should be sent down for
those who appealed
later this month we do have a team
reviewing all the appeal requests
and we're finding that about 25 to 30
percent of them
truly have a decision that is appealable
as for the lost wages benefits calvarada
says they are testing the system that
will disperse the funds
she says they also did apply for the
second round of the benefits in the next
three weeks
people should expect to see this they
don't need to do
anything additional to get the benefit
reporting in las vegas joe moeller
8 news now both the director and strike
force leader
go more in depth on those topics you
just heard about you can watch the
entire interview on our website
eightnewsnow.com
and if you're out there looking for a
job there are several companies that are
hiring right now
we put together a list along with links
where you can apply directly
on our website at 8newsnow.com just